[Music]
delta just announced this headline just
announced a brilliant plan to take a
bite out of this 100 billion dollar
industry straight out of apple's
playbook analysts have said they expect
that this summer will be the biggest
travel season ever big deal for the
airlines which have struggled over the
past two years with the covet 19
pandemic
millions if not billions of people who
have largely stayed close to home during
the pandemic are likely to venture out
to encourage those travelers delta just
announced a brilliant strategy
this is uh from delta's press release by
the way that they're into humility
and it's brilliant brilliant it's
brilliant remember those beer
commercials oh yeah
it's jumping on board with buy now
pay
later
bnpl
over the past years the buy now pay pay
later industry has exploded alongside
the surge in online shopping the idea is
that a shopper can spread out payments
usually over three to six months
buy now pay now pay later uh
representing a hundred billion dollars
in
2020 and uh delta once a piece actually
i think it's appropriate george because
with delta you usually buy now and fly
later i love that that's perfect
delta is greek for we ain't really going
oh my goodness and um it's a red it's
ridiculous and so now they're going to
go ahead and just get you get in the
finance business and you're financing
your airline ticket you did a whole
segment on the fine print on this buy
now pay later
which is it's an old it's an old thing
with a digital twist yeah i mean you
remember layaway back in the day but now
no layaway didn't have interest you had
to actually pay to get the product now
you get it right now instant
gratification
we don't have the patience we want to
just microwave everything have it right
now and that's what this is you talked
to people they got really stuck in this
they're buying little items but a lot of
them yeah and it's like it's a 30 item
and you got three payments of 9.99 or
something my god that's insane i was
just looking at the tweets today of just
people talking about these companies and
they're talking about it's 33 dollars
and i have the money but
i'm gonna do the after pay i'm gonna do
klarna i want to do it in seven dollar
payments for the next four months and
you can add more and more to that yeah
and well you you talk to people that
really got like credit card debt or
something they really got into a mess
with yeah lululemon that was we talked
to one girl who spent 10 grand with buy
now pay later on lululemon gear gotta
have it and so the mentality of this uh
what it says is i want it now and i
refuse to wait and save up and pay for
it when i can afford it and we're seeing
the klarna and after pay all these
companies they're bragging to retailers
saying hey if you use our product if you
use this service the customers will
spend 45 percent more
airlines have been completely buttholes
to their customers over over max masks
and vaccines
and now they they want to play nice you
know now they want to go yeah yeah
you don't even have to pay
it's like yeah we we know what you're up
to here boys and girls well they
literally say in the article you might
even spend more than you otherwise would
which is the biggest benefit to any
merchant that decides to let customers
pay over time even if you're not
collecting interest if you make more
sales for larger amounts that's a huge
win so you tell me who's winning here
the customers
no
it's the buy now pay later companies
it's delta not you see i thought rooms
there they went was the only place that
you did
you know
nothing down for 90. days nothing down
for 90 days right no payments for 90
days zero interest for 90 days 90 days
same as cash now we have your freaking
airline ticket
that's insane dave you're gonna love
this part it's a sign the world is truly
coming to an end
for a lot of reasons this is the check
this is the one that broke the camel's
back right here well no pun intended
with a camel sitting right here but
here's the thing dave it says in order
to take advantage of this new option you
have to use one of delta's co-branded
american express cards
you love that don't you oh yeah i love
america for delta that might be the most
brilliant part of all
yeah their company's relationship with
american express is quite possibly the
most valuable part of its business
i've heard all you here yeah let me help
you with this when corporate america
delta airlines
is so freaking stupid
that the only thing that they are
thinking about
when it comes to their customers
is how they can milk you like a dairy
cow
then they have lost their way
they are supposed to serve the customer
not milk the customer
this is this is when corporate america
is serving i i know that the stockholder
is king and i know you've got to make
your profits for q1 and q2 to keep your
little wall street people happy but if
you don't keep your customers happy you
go bye-bye and no one cries
so when delta goes bye-bye it's going to
be like some of these other people that
did nobody's going to be crying as a
matter of fact we may be doing a little
little ramsey dance in here oh i'll have
to invent that but it's not going to
you can't see it because it's not been
invented yet okay we'll film it when we
come up with it george you'll be the
first to see it thank you but i mean
yeah
my god
milk your customers this is a core value
of this company well they're getting a
lot of milk dave it says delta expects
this relationship to bring in as much as
seven billion dollars in revenue by next
year
seven billion
takes your breath and they're not even a
good airline no i mean this is tough
i mean it's just
when when i see delta come through and
and it shows up on my email as a ticket
i'm just always going oh god
you know i mean how many people do you
do business with that when you see them
come across and you're getting ready to
interact with them you sigh and groan
you know that feeling and that's what
this is and now now it's even worse now
it's even worse so yeah guys you brought
this on yourselves and uh as long as you
keep screwing your customers we're gonna
keep talking about you
and it ain't gonna be nice
so we'll just keep it up and don't fall
for this stuff guys guys really pay for
this you can afford a plane ticket
listen sit your little butt at home if
you don't have the money to fly come on
this is serious
well i need i need i need vacation shut
up stay at home
if you don't have the money stay at home
dave that hurts people's feelings
but i'm concerned about people's
feelings i've always been concerned
that's true feelings it's it's a big
thing with me so no i want you to have a
good life i don't give a crap about your
feelings i want you to win i want you to
retire a baby steps millionaire i want
you to be able to leave an inheritance
to your children's children not delta's
children
that means i can't do my instagram
instagram post from cabo dave
if i can't travel to cabo i can't do the
instagram
i said you couldn't travel unless you
couldn't afford it okay
i'm riding an air dave yeah that's an
airline that'll never say i might be
posting from cabo any minute it could
happen at any moment but i can freaking
afford to get down there and i'm not
having to finance my airline ticket even
worse wait on your your skyline miles
from your accrued credit card rewards to
afford to go somewhere that's an even
worse plan
this is like putting three stupid things
together american airline miles pay now
four stupid things okay airline miles
buy now pay later american express and
flying delta these are four stupid
things and they all want them to go bar
yeah it's like oh my gosh this is like a
lot of reasons to not do this
and i really don't see any reasons on
the plus side here
um
because they're going to treat you like
cattle when you get on there and hit you
with a taser if you don't wear your mask
just to suit them
they charge you for breathing now too
that's an extra charge breathing yeah
yeah breathing well that that'll that'll
increase revenue yeah that breathing
thing
that's popular leg room yeah carry-ons
you name it they'll get you
leg room yeah that's one you struggle
with that's true that's one of the many
benefits of being as small as i am
plenty of leg room i stretch out dave
you don't you don't have to have that
issue yeah that is a benefit it really
is thanks for letting me see the silver
lining there well i mean that's what
you're here for it saves you some money
george you don't have to try that extra
expensive seat oh yeah good times and
i'm short i don't have i'm not as short
as you but i'm short and i i don't have
the legroom thing either not an issue
for me i have a belly issue
sometimes that tray comes down it's a
problem yeah but um you don't have that
issue no so see everybody's got their
little everything's everybody's got
something they got to carry thank you
for that reminder there you go all right
we just we took it full circle i don't
know where the circle ended but it's
full i hope this circle doesn't go
unbroken
uh
oh my gosh
delta's not going to reach out for the
sponsorship now you know you don't think
we're going to think it's going to be
the ramsay show delta studio from the
delta studios it would be hilarious but
i don't see that in our future i don't
think that's happening i don't think
american express is signing up either
then i guess i'll just have to i'll just
have to live with that yeah you'll be
all right this is the ramsey show